Kobe Bryant's legacy lives on even in a
galaxy far far away on Sunday January
26th 2020 the former Los Angeles Laker
player husband and father of four died
at the age of 41 in a helicopter crash
the aircraft which was carrying Bryan's
his 13 year old daughter Gianna and
seven other individuals including the
pilot is said to been flying through
inclement foggy weather conditions which
may have contributed to the fatal wreck
Bryan's left behind his wife Vanessa and
three other daughters in the wake of
Brian's death fans are posted online
countless tributes to him remembering
Bryan for the person he was on and off
the course drawing that remembrance Star
Wars enthusiasts of recalled Bryan's
connection to the hallowed property
there's a character that was actually
inspired by him welcome to the Kobe show
day two the Kobe Bryant inspired Star
Wars character is a droid named k2
before a reference to both Bryant's
initials and his number 24 Los Angeles
Lakers Jersey which he began wearing
during the 2006 oh seven NBA season
after changing from his old number 8 jz
k to b4 appeared on three episodes of
the third season of the animated series
Star Wars the Clone Wars which takes
place in the three years between the
Star Wars prequel movies attack of the
clones and Revenge of the Sith a
feminine character who uses she/her
pronouns k2 b4 also sports a yellow and
purple color scheme the same palette of
the Lakers use according to Star Wars
comm but that find the Clone Wars
animation Department created k2b fourth
animation model the Lakers had won the
NBA championship has also been said that
the inclusion of k2 before in the series
was a nod to crew members to a Lakers
fans at E Series Sutter core droid k2b
for Southern Confederacy of Independent
Systems her biography details as she
experienced a lot she entered Lola Sayu
the planet containing the Citadel
without being detected
she got briefly tricked by battle droids
transporting r2d2 resulting in her
altering Citadel guards to capture the
droids and she boarded a lucre hog Droid
control ship but unfortunately failed to
keep a group of Jedi Masters
out of Lola Sayu if only K to be forced
win rate was as good as kobe bryant's as
it happens kobe bryant's ties to the
star wars property extend even further
than k2 before - announces then
impending retirement from the NBA which
came after the 2015-16 basketball season
Brian
spend a poem entitled dear basketball in
which he discussed his love for and
dedication to the sport weren't
eventually partnered with animator and
character designer Glen Keane who has
credits and films like Aladdin Beauty
and the Beast and The Little Mermaid to
turn dear basketball into an animated
short film always be there kid with the
wrong looks like garbage came in the
corner five seconds from a clock all in
my hands with keen animating and
directing and Brian star rating from the
poem he wrote the biggest thing left to
do was find someone to score the shots
the person they settled on was none
other than John Williams the legendary
composer who scored the film's and the
Star Wars franchise was even more
interesting as a dia basketball went on
to win the Oscar for best animated short
film at the 2018 academy awards ceremony
and star wars actor Mark Hamill Oscar
Isaac and Kelly Marie Tran presented
Bryant and Keane with the shiny golden
statue fans may even recall that Bryan's
walked onto the basketball court to the
infamous Imperial March from Star Wars
in December 2013 after a covering from
an Achilles tendon injury that
threatened to end his NBA career he also
once compared himself to the franchise's
most detroy as villain telling ESPN's
Baxter Holmes in December 2015 that he
sees himself as quote Darth Vader of
course with a smile Bryant added I don't
take orders from the Emperor
so Darth Emperor may be Darth emperor
doesn't have quite the same ring to it
as his famous nickname black mamba does
but no matter what you call them Kobe
Bryant will always have a place in the
Star Wars universe heroes come and go
but legends are forever
[Music]
you